non-minimalists
no matter what i do i find it difficult
to curb the urge to compulsively shop
especially on groceries
i've tried shopping fasts and wish lists
but they only help slightly
the only thing that really curbs it is
in person time with people i care about
but doing that on a regular basis isn't
possible for me at this time
burnt out i don't know what to do i feel
like i need shopaholics anonymous yeah
you might maybe you do yeah and
see the problem is you're saying this in
jest and that's actually what made me
look up shopaholic i'm like is this an
actual thing because i i was familiar
with the term obviously
and it's used pejoratively like oh yeah
i guess i'm like an alcoholic but for
shopping yeah yeah we are
we are that way
and it's okay there's no shame in
alcoholism no there's no shame in
shopaholic-ism
uh shopaholism um
whatever it is there's no shame in
shopping addiction right
it's as soon as we begin to understand
it though that's when these things can
go away now i will say ryan we were
talking a moment ago about the stories
that we tell ourselves the excuses
we tell ourselves and one excuse i have
here from shanti and maybe it's true for
her
doing that on a regular basis meaning
spending time with in people in person
she says doing that on a regular basis
isn't possible for me at this time
is is that true
and if it's not if it's not true
maybe it's more difficult for you at
this time yeah and maybe it has to do
with pandemics or maybe it has to do
with declining health or whatever i
understand but how can i do that now
because you've already understood the
why
the why for you is i go shopping when i
feel disconnected
johann hari who we've had on the podcast
talks about the nine causes of
depression and one of them is being
disconnected from human beings so maybe
the reason that you are
shopping
is because you feel so disconnected and
this is a way for you to try to become
connected
with the world around you we try to be
trendy so we become significant to other
people we try to get other people to
appreciate us through our status symbols
and the things that we acquire
we try to be a better person by buying
better
things
but
that doesn't fix what we're actually
missing what we're missing
in this case with shanti is we're
missing connection human connection
we're missing the relationships in our
lives and repairing the relationship
with the stuff
often happens on its own once we've
repaired our relationship with the
people in our lives it sounds like
she can't not afford
to be with other people is that can you
contract that ca and apostrophe nt
apostrophe nt yes you can can't
well but but in all seriousness it's
it's like when i hear someone talk about
oh well you know buying organic food or
healthy food is too expensive right and
it's like okay like i get that the
monetary cost of it
however
the long-term health effects like you
really can't not afford to like get the
help because it's going to cost you in
the long run anyway it's going to be
much more right with with healthcare
costs so
so yeah i mean i would i would challenge
shanti to
instead of shutting herself down
and saying oh i can't do this at this
time it's okay well what can you do
what are the things you can you know put
aside what what can you say no to in
order to say yes to having more
connection with people
um and i don't want to be you know
apathetic to shanti's situation maybe
she truly can't for some reason
um but i think that that would that's
more of an exception than it is like the
rule so that's right yeah be careful
with the stories you tell yourself
because even if they aren't true
they become true to you yeah and i'll
tell you shanti with the groceries
because that's she said especially on
groceries is where she's having the
difficulty you taught me this melbourne
where you go to the grocery store with a
list
and you get everything that's on the
list and nothing else nothing else and
let's say you
accidentally forgot to put rice on the
list it's like okay well i guess i'm
gonna have to come back you're creating
friction
to have to come back and get that rice
at a different time with a different
list yes um but but that's just one
example of the the different and we've
talked about a lot of different ways to
create friction but that's what shanti
needs to do so
uh have some relationships with real
life people but then also find ways to
create friction she said you know i
tried shopping fast and wishlist but
they help only slightly hey
slight slight help is better than no
help that's right and also those things
help only when you get to the why so
you've already identified the why now
the why
is i feel disconnected so i'm shopping
now that you understand that these
things that help slightly they're going
to help you so much more because you've
understood the nature of the problem did
you enjoy this video if so you can
listen to full episodes of the
minimalist private podcast available
exclusively on patreon visit patreon.com
the minimalists today your support keeps
our podcast and youtube channel 100
percent advertisement free